s'il est donc c'est ma grave interne aux
icaunais maeva des marseillais marina il
va gros dos allait bien mais tu vas voir
je pense tu vas kiffer tu connais pas je
connais pas trop là bas tu vas voir
regardez ma eva c'est parti regardez
vous allez faire crever faire
connaissance avec ces pros et deux
belges il est rappelé aux chiens gros
garde le clown foot foot du foot comme
quoi la route blanche et il nomme
nettoyer moitié nettoyer à tort ça fait
quand même mal en appel afin de pourquoi
tu visites je vais pas faire de la mer
mieux vaut garder à la fin de son nom
mais pourquoi ils changent mais où anne
de you've asie c'est bon on prend la
peine alors la vallée va donc voilà elle
avait l avatar dont elle est candidate
de télé-réalité elle s'appelle my valais
dans les marseillais actions
actuellement et maeva alice et de parler
anglais puisque l essayer de récolter de
l'argent pour des associations de
pouvoir rester dans l'aventuré seulement
voilà pour maeva savoir parler anglais
ne lui est pas paru important pour
réussir c'est l'objectif que vous avez
pu le voir
mais malgré ces difficultés en anglais
elle arrive tout de même à décrocher un
job dans un centre pour éléphant elle
doit ramasser leurs excréments
à mon avis c'était mon devoir manger
avant et regardez c'est trop compliqué
pour elle je vois que c'est une
catastrophe ce que je fais c'est je suis
complètement à côté de la plaque
donc j'ai rater mon job ouais j'ai raté
mon job
je suis trop dégoûté été très
impressionnés jobs annonce qu'elle a la
taille de ses crottes annonce a poussé
la caq a donné les fans de la taille
d'une pastèque mais c'est écoeurant mais
je peux pas c'est aulas
ok tu fais un petit break
en fait je risque d'être viré et leurs
enfants france mais je suis trop mal il
va alors à la production de fonte fans
voilà ils sont fans absolus de maeva oui
christine kelly
non non non je suis absolument déterminé
par ce genre de profil quoi tout
simplement c'est évident mais moins
actifs
oui et puis surtout elle a une
personnalité à quelque chose c'est pour
ça que les marseillais marche bien parce
que j'ai pas que physique un physique
non non non pas du tout mais je dis pas
qu'on s'identifie mais ils ont quelque
chose
voilà ils ont un tempérament parfois
volcanique et c'est franchement
l'émission fonctionne bien et elle a
plein d'expressions comme mme nabila en
on se demande ce n était pas dans le
même casse les deux mêmes et où regarder
les expressions 2020 ils vont aller
faire du kayak alors livre de caisse
blonde cela
un bond james bond c'est pas en
angleterre
baba maal et je suis catégorique je ne
parlerai plus à kevin et benji jusqu'à
ma mort moi quand j'ai une idée dans la
tête j'ai pas dans les faits c'est à
l'âge par là elle est fausse elle est
encore plus faux ce qu'une contrefaçon
en fait avec avaya toujours de vérité la
vraie vérité et le mensonge jure sur la
vie ta mère que je remets trois neveux
qui meurt d'une crise cardiaque sur la
vie de ma mère s'était jamais cela
relate on est chez nous allez moi j'ai
très peur
ces peurs des éléphants j'ai mangé ils
ont peur des chevals chez vous
ces balises sur mes fans au losc hcc
matthew regarder ce truc là où
auparavant n'ont jamais t'as jamais
regardé ça je sais pas je suis tombé
dessus mais jamais accroché
ouais non non c'est pas tu sais pas te
faire losange peut à la rigueur je
préfère que les jeunes regardent des
émissions où je sais pas où ça dans sa
chambre s